nuevas restricciones para los gigantes
de internet la unión europea aprobó una
ley antimonopolio que obligaría a
cambiar el modelo de negocio de grandes
plataformas digitales como apple google
meta y amazon y podría marcar un
precedente para que se creen
legislaciones parecidas en otras partes
del mundo acuerdo provisional con el
parlamento europeo sobre la legislación
de los mercados digitales un texto
innovador y muy necesario para
garantizar la competencia legal en los
mercados digitales la ley de mercados
digitales que entrará en vigor en 2023
prohíbe a las empresas combinar los
datos personales de sus usuarios permite
a los usuarios eliminar aplicaciones
instaladas por defecto restringe los
motores de búsqueda y los asistentes
virtuales y permite a los usuarios
instalar una tienda de aplicaciones
distinta a la que ofrece la marca del
dispositivo medidas que desde febrero
meta afirmó que afectarían directamente
su funcionamiento en el continente no
decíamos en absoluto retirarnos de
europa por supuesto que no pero la
simple realidad es que meta al igual que
muchas otras empresas organizaciones y
servicios dependen de la transferencia
de datos entre la unión europea y eeuu
para poder operar nuestros y globales al
menos otras 70 empresas de una amplia
gama de sectores también han planteado
los riesgos en torno a la transferencia
de datos para aquellas empresas que
incumplan la ley enfrentarán multas de
hasta el 10 por ciento de su facturación
anual y en caso de reincidencia las
sanciones podrían alcanzar un 20 por
ciento de sus ingresos anuales